foreign
[Music]
thank you everyone Thanks for uh thanks
for joining us for the session today uh
on accelerated cost savings with API
management
um hopefully everyone's had lunch and
caffeine although it is an exciting
topic
um you know I'm grateful for everyone
who's joined us here live in in San
Francisco
um so today I'll I'll talk to you
briefly about not just accelerated cost
Satan but also an increase in Innovation
that increasing speed of innovation that
comes with looking at apis more as
products than as an individual
technology itself
um my name is Neil Swartz I run outbound
product management for apogee here at
Google and and my path to API started
Way Way Back on network infrastructure
then went to Security application
security finding holes in various places
in infrastructure and apis and
ultimately led me here to to apogee here
at Google and in today's session we'll
also talk about business so not just
purely the technical underneath it but
the lives and the technology at the top
um there's one question my timer's not
running
which means I can hold you here longer
I guess
they're doing it cool I snuck in a few
extra minutes
um so on the business side I think what
we hear our customers talk about a lot
is that ideally the fastest path that
they can think of we would help them
with and that is to get their ideas and
their company value as quickly in the
hands of customers as possible and
ideally that's a straight line it's a
straight line into a product and from
there directly in the hands of customers
but as we all know it's not quite that
simple and certainly not when uh
customers are are changing how they want
to buy from you what they want to buy
from you how much they want to pay for
it Etc
now it's within within that context of
getting value as quickly as possible to
customers as we'll see in the
presentation apis play a very important
role but to start off first like why is
that role so important
is because the reality of working
towards this goal of getting your
services and products and value to
customers digitally that they're faced
with a multitude of not so straight
lines
it's a very easy path to to get from
idea to you know to another idea but how
do you get to execution and specifically
this digital Journey for organizations
that aren't the size of Google or that
aren't the size of you know 500 a
thousand ten thousand people
um those organizations tend to uh to run
into a couple of challenges and this is
just but one small piece of it
so firstly in order to develop any of
these digital Solutions there's the
actual development cost itself like what
do you or how many developers do you
have and what is it they spend most of
their time on so there's a challenge on
optimizing the velocity for Developers
on the other side there's the risk of
now you've developed something customers
show up and start using it in massive
quantities there's the hockey stick
effect that might happen in other words
now there's attention you have to spend
on not just setting up the
infrastructure once but supporting it
throughout this peak of usage or even
the reverse and that is cost optimized
for those cases where you're not using
it
all the way through to how do we secure
this plethora of decisions that led to
you creating a product and delivering it
to customers maybe not just within your
region but making your business
available to elsewhere in the world
and then lastly but certainly not the
least at the end of the day you're using
technology and building apis to get to
this outcome let's get the value from
the customer transformed into margin and
revenue monetization for you
so the starting point of this
presentation is like look there's a
plethora of
um challenges along the way to get to
this digital uh digital means of
communicating with your customers and
some of these patterns have repeated
itself and that's led us to create a set
of helpful technologies that ultimately
aim to solve some of these problems how
do we get customers value from your
organization faster
and three of the top questions that come
into mind with customers is is not just
sort of how much new technology are we
using how much of Google's keynote are
you using in your infrastructure but do
I know that I I have the best
infrastructure for my purpose am I using
the right things out of all the
possibilities that we have
are we spending like enough are we
spending too much could we optimize our
costs could we lower our our monthly
bill
um or could we utilize and swap out
entire Technologies so that certain
developers no longer have to focus on
infrastructure no longer have to focus
on repeating themselves and instead
focus on business Logic on top
and then lastly across all of this
security is often seen as a tax that is
applied at the end
but we're looking at this as look it's
not just security for Security's sake
it's how do we make sure the data of
your customers and your intellectual
property is kept safe but also the
systems so that you don't inadvertently
spend tons of money on for instance API
calls that end up nowhere
so while these questions are not unique
to apis it is a big challenge for
mid-sized organizations and above to
solve for some of this
and
I'm here to say as an advocate for apis
that the good news too is that apis
themselves offer a way for you to get
all those outcomes that is to say apis
power the majority of the digital
interactions that are out there today
and have done so for decades but they're
also a key area for further optimization
and one of the biggest things that
mid-size organizations or even earlier
stage companies have is not can you
build something but are you building the
right thing for your end customer
a large chunk probably more than
two-thirds of the Silicon Valley
Investments that go into companies end
up in awesome products but no one's
using them
so investing the right way but also the
right ideas and iterating fast is one
part of where we want to go and we've
seen that companies that start utilizing
an approach that favors looking at an
API as a product we see that they're
getting better results both on
optimizing but also finding the right
product to build
and in general over the course of about
12 months measured these companies that
have taken a strategic approach to apis
end up generating more of them which you
know self-serving is obviously
beneficial to to us
but for apis in particular and all of
the ideas that you can help unlock there
are sets of other strategies at play too
and we've captured all of those um those
strategies and all those capabilities in
a set of a set of services that no
longer is just available to the largest
companies out there but it's available
from whatever usage you have from the
first API call you have up to the
billions that you have
um and this is sort of the area of API
management you've heard of it as API
management or full lifecycle API
management but the case in point is that
an API represents a contract it's the
contract it's delineation between your
group and the organization that builds
sets of business logic and a partner or
a business unit or you know an ecosystem
developer that ends up wanting to use
your infrastructure and I I'd call it a
contract for a very specific reason it's
an agreement between you and the other
party to not change that portion of your
functionality
if you've done so you can iterate more
quickly on the back end faster using
Technologies such as the ones we're
talking about here
it's important to note that it's for for
any use case
um quite literally it could start off
with simple integration use cases all
the way through to developer ecosystems
that end up in multiple digital portals
of various kinds where new modes of
communication are taken care of at the
end of the day they're all API calls and
they all represent similar value but
also similar challenges
and it's this any scale that we
mentioned in particular in the current
economic climates to say look you
shouldn't just have to lock yourself
into massively long contracts but
utilize exactly what you need and know
more and spin down as you no longer
needed
the other side of this from a cost
optimization perspective is that
oftentimes when you pick a technology or
you decide a strategy around apis as
products all of a sudden additional
constraint constraints and concerns show
up from a security perspective this is
not just the basic you know am I
authenticating the right person or the
right system am I authorizing them the
right thing but also what type of
attacks do I need to defend against what
do I not know yet from a tax perspective
what is all this new technology like gen
AI going to do with the consumption of
these apis
so there's an entire class of problems
in the security space that tended to
mean you have to have a separate set of
tools or a separate department for it
but we believe that that's not
necessarily the case you shouldn't have
to do that and then lastly for every
developer we we strongly believe that
some of this technology should be
available not just to a specific size
company for all of them but also enable
the use of these apis for any type of
developer whether or not you're sort of
a hardcore directly into the weeds
developer or someone who prefers sort of
more visual tools more Loco tools
so
for us apis we're not just part of how
we got to where we are but we also think
it's a fundamental enabler this contract
to this product for new technology in
the future
and there are a couple different areas
for further maximizing value of these
apis like how do we do more with it it's
great that there's technology but at the
end we want to get as much value out of
it as possible as possible there's sort
of three different categories that we
look at here including some interesting
announcements
so one part of this is at the end of the
day you could stand on the shoulders of
someone else when you utilize someone's
API so how do you get your ideas faster
to life faster to your end customers or
the potential end customers and
standardize that access and reduce the
need for specialized skills for them to
take and make use of this back backend
service
the middle section of this do more with
less I run part of product management
and I'm always told by our engineering
team like that's great you want 100
things done but in reality we're only
going to fund 10 of those how would you
apply that same prioritization mechanism
to your own business by just carefully
selecting where you invest and where you
reuse
and then lastly we talked a little bit
about the security side there's much to
be said on that topic we have some
separate sessions for that that are
recorded and made available just to look
at how we bring more security
capabilities in the hands of the people
who want to build apis but aren't
necessarily Security Experts
how do you not burden your teams with
security overhead
so with that in mind let's start with
the build faster how do we get
um how do we get your ideas encapsulated
into reality Faster by utilizing apis
so one part
um of what we've announced and we're
announcing here at Google next is is
this notion of helping people go from
from a let's call it a novice API idea
to something that is an expertly crafted
API specification that could almost
instantaneously be utilized as an api's
product
and what I'm showing to you here on
screen is is duet AI cooperating with
apogee to help craft API specifications
and ultimately deploy this inside of
apogee again the goal here is to help
those developers that want to focus most
of their attention on something else but
have to make sure that this service is
made reusable for others made
discoverable
and part of what we're doing here is
enabling an IDE experience where certain
prompts are put in like accept purchase
orders for specialized coffee beans
through a web API
the very first part of this is that we
take you know General understanding of
what API specifications are and help
suggest the specialized statements that
go in there
now at certain scale once you started
using this what becomes interesting is
that these specifications that are
offered
um will start to be made better based on
other specifications that it has access
to
specifically for mid-size organizations
assume that you have a catalog of all
apis that becomes input to train this
case the model to help your teams be
more effective get to API specifications
that are built with this idea of product
first in mind and get to ideas faster
what we're announcing later here in next
two is that there's a trusted tester
program that you can you can apply for
at the end of the slides
but this is one of many places where we
think that we can accelerate the
development of those ideas into value to
your customers by making use of
Technology again not technology for
Technology's sake but for an end goal
another part of this too is to make the
technology fit into more of the use
cases that you might have and without
draining the entire slide at the end of
the day an API gets processed somewhere
before it's fed to multiple different
back-ends
part of this is what we call the runtime
that takes care of all the functions
that we briefly spoke about
and one of the developments in this area
is to make it possible to load a set of
policies across all the apis you have
we'll call that standard API proxy and
that could be used as a starting point
to just put up a facade in front of a
new service that a team has been
building without really bothering too
much about what the ecosystem is that
you're building around it
and then contrasting that with what we
call an extensible API proxy which is
essentially Soup To Nuts everything that
everyone knows about API management
detailed policies authentication
authorization Transformations
ecosystem management developer
management
Etc
now the reason I just even touched this
here is that the the tooling that is now
available allows your organization to
move fast while already standardizing on
on the technology that will be helpful
to Monitor and ultimately monetize these
apis uh in the protection of course as
well
and on that note another part of um of
the overall offering that we think is
really relevant for mid-sized companies
and above and even smaller companies is
this notion of being able to start off
with an API
again generated for instance with duet
Ai and then fast iteration in the back
end using what we call application
integration
the notion here is that humans by
definition want to optimize for their
own time and we agree we want to do the
same thing and what we've noticed is
that workflows and Integrations
typically tend to follow a number of
fixed patterns that always start off
with a trigger on the left hand side
most of the time as an API call set of
data Transformations a set of conditions
that are brought in and ultimately a set
of connectors to either drop in or fetch
additional data that entire sort of
Suite of functionality is being
Rewritten hundreds of thousands of times
and instead of doing so what we're
suggesting here is take this approach of
projecting value to customers through an
API
turning that into a contract that
doesn't change for your partners or for
your
um your development partners and at the
back end iterates super fast on what
that workflow can look like and once
you've settled on something that's of
value for your end customers then you
can further optimize and maybe further
enhance it and that's what in this case
a visual path of helping you iterate
faster these Integrations
so all of that the main attention is
bring ideas to Market faster because
that's one of the big differentiators
that you you have by utilizing
technology
again not technology for Technology's
sake but for a particular purpose
the other section or the other big area
where we think there's more optimization
possible in maximizing value is to look
at well how do we take what was
originally true for large organizations
and slice and dice it down to a set of
usage patterns that fit your
organization
and without going into details of the
commercials one of the things we've
noticed is that these technologies that
are available for apis would like like
to follow the model of exploring your
ideas first trial it when with what we
have and then matching it with either a
short-term contract literally whatever
you use is ends up being paid for or go
for longer term fixed cost setups with
subscriptions the only reason I bring
this up again is to show you that this
is not just technology available for
large organizations it is in fact very
helpful for for smaller teams and
smaller organizations too
the other big advance in this area is to
say well that's great we have technology
we have an API management platform we
have something like a product but how am
I going to make my case for other parts
of the organization or how am I going to
help other teams do work for me as the
API developer in this case
and one thing we've noticed is that
um oftentimes a lot of the analytics
data from apis the behavior of certain
clients certain applications that come
in or the relevancy of the developer
program like how many people have
um you know active developer tokens for
apis that type of technical information
is not just relevant for uh for the
teams that run the platform but also for
teams that are on the business side who
know more perhaps of the financial
transaction that happens the you know
the rate at which people will complete
purchases the reports that have to be
generated around costs the reports that
that varies Folks up in the treatment
have and one of the things we've done is
like rather than having you create
further Integrations why don't we just
create the capability that all the data
that pertains to these apis is made
available in a business intelligence
platform in this case Booker data studio
and with that immediately an entire host
of reporting questions and data
analytics questions is moved away from
the harder core technology of API
management into the realm of pure data
intelligence so we bring API information
that's in apogee we bring that over into
looker for intelligence we also do that
in a cost-effective way by not just
copying a bunch of stuff make it
available as a data source and then
either come up with standard dashboards
or use AI inside looker to ask natural
language questions about data sets about
how the joining of two or three or five
data sources ends up with a result for
this API program or this type of action
that's taken
so with that we're bridging between the
various technologies that are there and
we're doing it without turning that into
your problem and we think that's sort of
a pattern that we're we're trying to get
to
and then lastly on sort of maximizing
value this is only so good to the moment
that you can trust it and the trust
Factor here is is critically important
we think and it's important because it's
all your data it's a new entry point in
your organization
and what we've done there and we'll keep
doing is riding along with everything
else that the larger Google Organization
has made available and is announcing
here in
um in Google next as well and that is
conceptually to take the information we
already have about these apis about the
the ecosystems that you've created the
transactions that pass through
take that analytics data and unleash
sort of security models on top of it
so not just look at policies that are
created but also the activity on these
apis what is anomalous behavior from a
pure API perspective that's what
analytics offers today what do we want
to add on top of it things like bot
detection like who is scraping our data
who's going off with all the you know
the purchasing behavior that you have or
the entire price list catalog you have
or is
um you know maliciously impacting
marketing numbers based on fake requests
that come in
to all of this all rides on the same
information and the past World it meant
that all this information had to be
given to a security department expensive
enough so what we're doing here is we're
bringing those security capabilities to
the API management platform and in this
case riding along with what's already
collected
running models against it models against
the traffic
and it's the same machine learning
models that are utilized for larger
Google properties in the outside world
and continuously recognize activities
that don't really fit well with the
normal behavior
and obviously identifying it is great
but if I tell you there are a thousand
things wrong you clearly want to know
the next step which is what are you
going to do about it and that's where a
set of mitigating actions can be taken
by the same API platform again it
doesn't matter if you go you know the
the you only have a few apis or you've
got billions of API calls the same
capabilities exist and are made
available
and in this case mitigation can mean
many things it can mean look we don't
want to actually receive this traffic
whatsoever
or we want a signal to your business
logic in the back end this looks kind of
funky we've received it from a certain
geography we've seen certain behavior
that makes us think that this is not
really legitimate traffic but we don't
know enough yet we want you to make a
next call then it might be that you know
you're you're not going to give this
particular product to someone else or
you know you'll lose some extra fraud
checks in the back end
the key though is that the problem of
securing these apis becomes a
collaboration between your team in this
case uh us an apogee and your security
organizations and the context is shared
between the two
and this at the end of the day all leads
us to
um to a set of main questions that is do
we have a way to look at apis not just
as technology but as a way to unlock and
to explore new and open new use cases
for end customers
and we think the answer to that is
absolutely true yes we see many of our
customers generate new revenue streams
on the basis of creating apis and they
firstly started off with using apis pure
list integration technology and started
moving in the direction of more
ecosystems creating adjacencies by
integrating with partners that are
adjacent to them creating net new entry
points for new customers all the way
through to
all the way through to capabilities that
allow you to engage with newer Styles
developers that work in entirely
different fashions
so apis really are at the front door to
every digital asset that you have in
your organization
and one particular example of a company
that's gone through this journey with us
and is still on this journey is this
company called L'Oreal everyone knows
them large Beauty brand
but what's fascinating to take away from
from this particular example is they
move from the origins of apis as purely
means to get faster communication
between disparate parts of the
organization to sharing more services
with other groups in other words
promoting reuse reducing costs by
varying the costs across multiple
business units all the way through to
new capabilities in apis as products
that are created by engaging developers
marketing organizations with the product
sets they have through digital means
and again this is a multifaceted not
just purely one API technology but the
starting point is an API is a product
turns into a contract where the party in
this case L'Oreal has the capability to
iterate fast on the inside of the
organization while the outside can rely
on a known interface into the
organization that is trusted and
protected
and in general what this points at is is
a concept that I've not named but I've
talked about here another is to rope in
the platforms more and more to abdicate
functionality into and for those of you
who are closer to software development
you've heard the industry and we're part
of that too
we've heard you've heard us talk about
shifting left moving certain
functionality whether or not it's from a
code quality perspective to security
vulnerabilities move all that burden
closer to the earlier stages of product
development or in this case software
development in building and development
let's move most of the technology left
in addition to that though we've seen
that that generates sets of concerns
with development organizations we're not
trying to turn everyone into a security
expert we're not trying to turn everyone
into an API expert some folks are
dedicated mostly to business logic and
they should be and the the term that
we've we've worked on here is to focus
on shifting down
in this case shift the burden of some of
these integration capabilities some of
these API capabilities further down into
the platform so that you're freeing up
your development resources to work on
the things that truly create value that
are differentiated to you and we think
that you know by by making use of apis
and looking at them as products
utilizing a platform that helps you
secure it and go faster we get this
Nifty model where you can shift that
burden further down while controlling
cost in running that platform
so we've got Jeff one more term not just
shift left but we also want to shift
this functionality down into the
platform and we're happily we'll we
happily do this for lots of customers
and we happily do it for more
and just to sort of prime more ideas
um there's sets of examples here of
companies that have used apis as their
core strategic tenant to explore and
open new revenue streams and they're not
just limited to Pure tech companies like
Financial Services everyone here
probably knows stripe their biggest
product is essentially an API there are
many of them right now but the key thing
is they've spent so much time
developing and crafting the API
itself and helping developers get into
this ecosystem that they've now become
the de facto standard in payments
likewise for other technology companies
twilio is very well known source for
anything communication related if you
ask a crowd of developers like who's
really sent a text message using Old
School Technology the answer right now
is like mostly none like everyone uses
something like Twitter for it
but the core there is it is a product in
this case it's the API and your teams
can depend on it because there is a
contract
all the way through to not just
capabilities that are technical nature
but also data sharing so think of your
organization what data can be made into
value for partners or for other
departments
one very prominent example AccuWeather
where they're exposing data for specific
audiences tailored for specific
audiences
you know in addition to the primary
Outlets that they have in separate
applications
all the way through to look maybe you're
not into Data necessarily or into
technology or payments financial
services but looking at how you
communicate with a community how you
communicate with a set of your end users
slack and Shopify are two prime examples
where the Baseline experience is
delivered but extended using apis as
product
or for Shopify where buying experiences
are tailored entirely for new sets of
audiences again possible using apis as
products
to improve virality of products or get
the the product information out there in
more places
the key at the end of the day for us is
that apis as products provide us a way
to
um deliver the capabilities in a far
lower cost than was possible in the past
with far fewer people necessary to get
the get them done and scale it up to
multiple new revenue streams across the
world
I'd say with that we've got some time
left over for questions but I'll get to
that only after saying look there's a
trusted tester program that we're
opening as part of apogee and this is
for the various generative AI based
additions to uh to apogee and Google
that were that we've been announcing so
again one of it is cloud code or vs code
extensions and there are sets of other
enhancements
um around plugins that are being made
available too so if you're interested in
that please register in The Trusted
tester program
thank you
[Applause]